[Music]
it's all hands on deck in Ireland's
Hospital crisis these private sector
paramedics have been drafted in to help
free up national Ambulance Service Crews
respond to 999 calls and overcrowded
hospitals to discharge their patients
faster if patients don't move out of
hospitals to out of freeing up the beds
um
it's going to get worse and that is our
role and it's a vital role that we move
patients as as quickly and efficiently
as we can to free up the beds for those
who really need them and plenty do the
number of emergency department patients
waiting on trolleys is at a record high
since nurses began counting them in 2006
among the worst affected hospitals is
University Hospital Limerick Marie
McMahon's husband Tommy died on a
trolley at Uhl in 2018 he had spent 36
hours waiting for a bed the hospital
apologized to the family but Marie says
the current situation shows the problem
hasn't been solved it was just traumatic
there were people lying on trolleys
trolley to trolley people screaming out
for a bed pen people being sick
people silent themselves people on their
own in absolute agony nor privacy no
dignity no respect
one doctor on the front line at Dublin's
Bowman's Hospital says the situation in
Irish hospitals is life-threatening
it's very definitely dangerous and we
know that and from the fact that
patients who attend emergency
departments that are markedly
overcrowded are more likely to suffer
preventable death so it is undoubtedly
dangerous and it needs to be addressed
but the Health Service executive says it
doesn't know if people are dying as a
result of the crisis have people died
because of this hospital overcrowding so
it's difficult for me to answer that
with any certainty and we know from a
study done in the NHS that
um delayed admission to hospital coming
through any department is associated
with additional mortality but surely at
this stage it is a safe assumption to
say that people have died because of
this current crisis
the health service has put in place
emergency measures and trolley numbers
are down on last week's but flu levels
are weeks away from peaking and doctors
say Ireland needs 5 000 extra beds to
solve the overcrowding problem
investment is needed time is needed for
now patience and Frontline workers will
continue to Bear the Brunt
Stephen Murphy Sky News Dublin